hey guys I'm Ryan right
so we're gonna watch the trailer today
for if I believe it's called the order
the order 1886 is up again or 1886 what
you got you got like two-thirds of the
name I hope order I know what you're
talking about okay good good do you know
you guys anything about this game looks
awesome
it looks awesome and what from my basic
understanding it's sort of like a like
some like horse it's like a horse
shooter is basically the genre horse
shooter yes a horse shooter it's gonna
be shooter its horror based so it looks
paranormal kind of thing yes that's fine
look what's the but you must way to
describe this before so I can think on
the spot i speaking the rabies
Elena committed powers out of the
basement
oh [ __ ]
they also have crazy plasma I'm sure
they can find
we figured out how to make a railgun but
like walkie talkie communication
get away yeah first I was like hey this
looks like resident evil then when he's
eating him I was like okay this is just
Resident Evil and then it just got like
crazy from there
escalate why you wouldn't pull out your
gun like immediately and there's merit
I'm just gonna wait one second I want to
see what he's gonna do bigger just a few
more seconds just a few more seconds for
science you guys know anything about
like the main character or anything is
that the main characters that are you're
shooting you're blowing out it looks
like it just gets killed
I'm not sure exactly how the plot lines
gonna roll out kind of seems like right
now from what I've gathered it's very
much like there's some paranormal
activity go kill it is kind of seemed it
was good I've actually seen like any
details unlike the actual storyline
about what the whole thing's gonna be
some paranormal stuff and yeah the
second it went in the gameplay and he
was running away from it yes yeah yeah I
would not want to be behind the
controller it's like one thing seen
through horror movies and everything to
be like let's be if you die in a horror
game it's your oh it was your own damn
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
thanks let us know about that first of
all if you need a channel can subscribe
here and if you want to subscribe of a
dance channel you can subscribe right
here to that cyber Channel and leave a
nice comment about Jacob
something very JQ i say that he's
looking dashing you probably much chill
guy I've ever met
Thanks trying to flange it for him like
you came home I was like whoa we can do
this yeah whatever
pick one word la let's do what do you
want to do for guys I haven't seen the
previous two videos it sounds like
you're lovers it sounds like you are
only if you haven't seen the previous
two you're like I picked them up from
the airport
planning what I wanted to do with him
maybe I read into it too much you Ryan
come back where are you going watch this
it will sound like it just happened it
just happens with bromances eventually
you hit the old bro couple fans it's
like what do you want to drink you just
hug it out they should do a bromance
where they end up hooking up ghostly
icon
I would love a shout out you spelled at
WOD quotation marks hinting penis love a
shout-out that will be awesome
haha he thought he was really funny on
that one too I wonder if he actually did
yeah Ryan's gonna love this one
yeah you earned the Shadowman money to
go buddy ghostly icon what does that
mean it's an icon that's got like 50%
opacity so just under there yeah
more likely to believe anything with
dick involved that's true well I think
we can convince still whatever fact I
want now is like I can do what they did
and you see links dick in the legend is
Oh Ezra he said shout-out please okay
Ezard
there you go Jenna Shadow accomplished
hazard equal sign lowercase B mmm as we
put em hmm interesting
yeah what does that mean Oh miss Betty
he said check out the crew official
trailer I thought we did we did we did
do that did it and please shout out Ryan
love your reaction videos okay buddy
Thomas Beatie
this is your shout out show oh you are a
beautiful human being and don't you ever
forget it don't listen to your mom she
sometimes that's called emotional abuse
my friend this is no she's gotta be
yourself Thomas no I'm just that's the
problem is you mom is not supporting I
mean the basketball game [ __ ] the
basketball logo is a problem he's not
his mom's not supporting him and being
part of the NBA like he wants to be you
know cuz the name's Thomas B he's
obviously it's like some white Irish kid
and you know he wants to be part of the
you know the National Black Association
but he's not gonna do it man this video
got really offensive fast Wow really
offensive quite the callback though
there we go
so that's called connection my friend I
connect it with you on a personal level
I hope we see him and might be NBA in
late for years that the camera point
says dick